tell me your character's name again I'm
playing rocky and I'm playing miles
chance the main character I'm playing
his friend in it I what is Hollywood
friend Oh interesting and is that as
that a friend of me you know what I
never really judged my characters I
think that a distance is like yourself
from the actual character so so I have
you you have to justify everything so
I'm not gonna be like oh I'm a friend of
me or I'm a bad guy I'm a dude who has
his reasons for what he does you know
there's there's a reason obviously for
better or worse that I'm friends with
them but I don't know what I really call
it the sides uh you know a Hollywood
friend I'll leave it at that okay so
that's interesting so you don't judge
the character so then you don't want to
feel like they're good or bad either
yeah I mean like if you're if you're
playing a serial killer if you talk to
most like like there's a lot of
interviews on on killers or bat horrible
human beings they don't actually believe
they're a bad person they have a
justification and so I think every
person i mean that's in a really extreme
case but i think that every when you're
playing a certain character you can't
really i mean it's hard not to sometimes
because you'll look anybody wow that's a
really mean thing to do or that's a but
you kind of gotta not pay attention to
that and really come up for reasons and
just to justify what you do in it if
that makes sense kind of like you can't
really judge yourself or then it's kind
of an outsider perspective and it's not
really the real realistic perspective
you've had if you were being that person
you